let's check in next with oh oh how about
Elias from Texas Elias welcome
hey David
hi yeah your audio is already glitchy
but what's going on you hear me yes I
can
oh
um
it is the start of Hispanic Heritage
Month tomorrow will you teach your
daughter any Hispanic Traditions or
teach her Spanish how important is your
Hispanic identity to you hold on
Hispanic Heritage Month starts in the
middle of the month
yeah that's weird that doesn't really
mean are you sure about that usually um
it starts on the first yeah yeah
let's see yeah
it's start that you're completely
correct that's bizarre but you're
completely right wow Elias okay I
exclusively speak Spanish to my daughter
so the idea will be that she with with
me and with my parents she oh we only
speak Spanish to her yes
was that your only question do you
no I'm saying like do you have any like
traditions that you're also gonna like
teach her or absolutely well she's going
to be well versed in the eating of
milanesa I can assure you uh as well as
you know empanadas and all of these
different things yes there's going to be
all sorts of traditions she's going to
get the best of both worlds she'll get
the Argentinian traditions and the
Jewish tradition so you know latkes and
the entire thing pastrami you know
that's amazing yeah so so
um how how important is your Hispanic
identity to you it must be pretty
important since you're you're passing it
down to your daughter absolutely I don't
want that to be lost and you know to
some degree I mean listen
five generations from now if my
descendants remain in the United States
I think it will probably be lost
inevitably it's very hard to keep it
right indefinitely but for now I'll do
what I can
right yeah all right uh that that's
basically it thank you all right Stephen
thank you so much there is Elias from
Texas always important to make every
effort to pronounce people's names
correctly let's go next to let's try Roy
from South Jersey Roy what's going on
Roy from South Jersey you are on the air
can you hear me now yes I can sir
um I have in my phone a list of topics
that I'd like to discuss whenever I come
on but this is too pressing for just a
regular list yeah I went to I'm in I'm
in Florida yep uh and I went to a
supermarket and I saw something I saw a
my pillow store in the supermarket now
wait a second you are you that sounds
more like something that would happen in
Florida but you said you're in Florida
uh yeah Florida yeah oh wow no okay uh
well that's in so there's a my pillow
store inside of another store that's
interesting
I was very uh worried that they would do
a class action lawsuit against me but um
anyway
um you know I really like how you've
challenged a lot of uh grifters over the
years like Dave Rubin but uh everyone
has a price so my question to you is
um if say Bill Gates or Elon Musk or
whoever said I will pay you however much
yep name your price but I want you to go
on the air on your show in a um Tony the
Tiger uh costume and say I love kids
menus they're great what would your
price be oh that I mean that's not I
thought you were gonna say to like
become a conservative on the air for the
next decade or something like that I
mean that sounds kind of funny I would I
would do that for you know I don't know
make me an offer if that's interesting a
Tony the Tiger outfit and saying that
they're great that that I would uh I
would do for a lot less and then I would
take 90 of the money and put it back
into causes I agree with
all right thank you all right Roy I hope
uh my answers were satisfactory there is
Roy from South Jersey